it's basically all my videos almost all
of them
are a little mini lesson
in how important love is in a kid's life
unconditional love that's it love
forgiveness and help but love is most
important obviously yeah that's how I
see it so Peter your your story you have
an interesting story your yours a little
different than most of what I do right I
figur that's the reason why I'd email
you and I figured that you you'd call me
within a day cuz there's nothing like it
yeah I mean it's common more common you
think but not for what you've
done tell me tell me how it
started how the accident started
yeah well um I was in a coma for two
weeks so I woke up and a lot of it got
erased but basically what happened
was it was a normal day I went to go
pick up my son I had him in private
school which is very expensive but I
wanted him to get a decent education he
was my first
born I picked him up I'd always get
there 15 minutes early cuz I missed him
so much and I just loved him so much
we're best
friends and picked him up went to a
friend's house nearby we usually stopped
there for 15 minutes to an hour hang out
and then I'd either take him to an
aquarium like a pet store which was
nearby and then go home or sometimes we
just go
home so we visited my friend hung out
for a little while and I said all right
I got a phone call from my wife saying
that the food was done so I told him hey
buddy we got to get home and he said no
no no I was person of the day-to-day at
school I was like all right well I'll
take you and get a fish for your
aquarium another fish he's like all
right I never made it there so so that
was a head- on collision head-on
collision yeah he jumped over the
median and uh slammed right into
me my wife and family went and looked at
the accident scene I never breaked I
never saw him
coming so big Yukon and I was in a Ford
Rancher
so and you survived and barely and the
other driver survived yeah he uh he got
out of the car and tried to escape but
there was an undercover cop in back of
me who had his uh who just happened to
have his camera on so that got the whole
thing but your son did not he died
instantly from what they said yeah 6
years
old yeah it's yeah I mean it's the worst
thing you can uh it's the absolute worst
thing someone can deal with in The Human
Experience um you're wired to lose your
parents and you're wired to either I'm
going to lose my spouse or my spouse is
going to lose me but you're not supposed
to lose a child especially a young child
I
mean and I I missed out on so many
things and I never saw it coming and it
was all because somebody made a big
mistake you know I know that he wasn't
he wasn't trying to kill us but he made
a decision that it's going to affect me
for rest of my life he was he was drunk
he was drunk uh on methamphetamine and
he was smoking pot
supposedly um the accident team which I
guess is really good in Pomona they said
um what happened was as he kned off you
know from being on meth for a few days
and he jumped over the med and slammed
down into me 45 miles an
hour um right on my side and usually my
son sat on the other side so he could
see me but that time he wanted to be
close to me and he's kept putting his
arm around my shoulder and like telling
me he loved me
and yeah
so this was how many years ago this is
may they shut down the whole street
obviously because there was a you know
somebody died they made local news it
was all over Facebook and that kind of
thing
and let me tell you comments brings out
the worst in people you know they don't
and I get it they don't know the whole
thing maybe some of them aren't
extremely educated or they're just one
of those people that rush to say
something you know people are human and
they said the worst worst things in the
world
so about what about well when he hit me
beer cans flew from his his
vehicle um so they're all over the place
so the media said we're both
drunk also I had two bottles of liquor
that I had gotten in a State sale it was
one of those things where everything's
gone come to the state sale and grab
whatever you want and get it out of here
cuz we need it out of here so I found an
old bottle of socki and old bottle of
wine and the date was pretty bad on it
but I didn't know anything about it so I
figured I'd give it to a homeless person
say I don't know what the issue is but
if you want to try it go ahead maybe
drink a little bit at first but I didn't
want it to go to waste and I wanted to
brighten somebody's day and yes you can
brighten somebody's Day by giving them
alcohol or giving him something I mean
it's just for a few minutes or an hour
makes him feel okay and I understand I
get that now especially yeah I
understand that too uh I think they
probably broke and that's why the smell
of alcohol was on my car reason why they
smelled alcohol on me um did they test
your alcohol blood alcohol uh yes they
did um and my mother had it done at the
hospital because she didn't want any
issues um and when the call when the cop
called me when I came
to uh he asked me if he could have it
and I said well didn't you take blood
cuz in the report it said you guys took
he said yeah it's going to take a few
weeks so so I sent it to him and yeah
you know we're fine so so you did not
have no
yeah and how do you how do you carry on
with life after
that
um well I
mean in the beginning of course it
doesn't really hit you it's you're kind
of in
denial
um when I was when I was in the hospital
it took me about 2 weeks to come out of
the
coma and and I was told you know that I
was an accident but I had so many coma
dreams that I I thought that I knew what
happened I thought I got into a small
fender bender in Mexico and that
everybody was
overreacting and in the dreams it was
just like this I mean it was as real as
I could tell you where I've been places
I did uh things I did places I went it
was unbelievable so I was F that I was
sure that they were full of it
so my mom told me that had been in an
accident and I uh I said where and she
told me I was like you know what the
hell was I doing there none of it made
sense and then she told me that I had I
had two strokes and I was like it just
seem so foreign to me cuz I seemed kind
of normal and I asked for a mirror I
looked at my face my face wasn't crooked
so I I thought that people weren't being
honest with me people were definitely
holding something from
me so I uh
started to put the pieces together I
started to come two more and then after
a couple days I asked for my phone
because I wanted to you know I have I
have a small business at the time and I
wanted to answer questions and but they
were reluctant to give it to me and so I
told him that's my phone I'm an adult
like just bring my
phone and basically they'd come to visit
me between 8:00 a.m. till like 10:00
p.m. and they brought me my phone and
when they left
you know I went to Google and I typed in
my name accident and there's a picture
that had just taken of my son like a
week and a half two weeks prior over and
over and over again and it said
six-year-old killed in
DUI and immediately I didn't know what
was going on I thought I thought that it
was me that that killed him so then I
started reading the story and I was like
some 19-year-old hit me and he had a
prior DUI
and and uh it just didn't make sense I I
was sure like no they he has to be here
like this this
impossible so I called my
wife and um I asked if Jules was
there and she said yeah yeah he's here I
said put him on the phone and she hangs
up on
me I call my mom my mom doesn't
answer and then immediately uh a very
good friend of mine and his wife show
up and I just point Blake CK him I said
look I'm going to ask you something I
don't want you to lie to me you got to
tell me the truth is my son
dead and he said why why why are you
asking that I said because I just read
it in the news he's like why don't you
show me where it's at he was trying to
buy himself every second that he could
and his wife already left the room
trying to call my wife to explain what
happened my wife wanted to keep it from
me because I had a couple surgeries
coming up and she wanted to make sure I
didn't just turn off and just give up
and
die so uh my friend starts crying and
says he's so sorry he doesn't even know
how to how do you talk to somebody and
tell them they lost their
child so my wife ends up showing up with
my mom and my very best friends and
that's how she wanted to let me know
that you know along with the pastor
principal of the school that my son went
to
and I still couldn't believe it like I
knew that he'd passed but it just it
doesn't
connect but two Days Later of being home
I saw like a little toy gun that my son
played with and was on the floor and I
knew that he was never going to touch
that again and little things like that
is when it started to hit me that like
he's
gone
um he was with me and he passes away the
next time I see him was at the funeral I
mean I saw my son in a box that's the
next time I saw him everything got
erased because I was in a coma and I
didn't and he passed
away so after the funeral I grabbed his
hand and I kissed his forehead and he he
was
freezing and I knew that that was the
last time I was going to see my
son you know somebody else's
mistake but I know it's mine to deal
with now you can't keep saying well you
know he's the cause of all my
issues but
um yeah it's it's difficult yeah no
nobody wants to lose a kid and I know
pretty much everybody has drink and and
drove a vehicle that's it's so common
and most of the time nothing happens but
I mean all you need to do is slip for
one second and something bad can
happen well yeah
yeah so
uh from the
accident the cop who was behind us ran
to to the man first who jumped out of
the car and he said no just just relax
you know just just sit right
here and then he went to my vehicle and
there was blood all over my face and he
said I was
unresponsive basically um every bone in
my left leg broke from my uh femur all
the way to my calcinus my ankle my
sternum broke which damaged my heart my
nose my jaw broke ribs 5 through seven
broke which is right side and I had two
strokes uh one in the front of my brain
and one in the rear of my
brain so um at 38 years
old so um I barely pulled out the day of
the accident they told my wife and my
mom to start calling everybody cuz I
could go at any time and I was hanging
by a thread
so and uh
slowly I pulled out and I was able
to but who really wants to live after
something like
that you know
um it's
amazing you know people want to friends
and family and people they want to help
and they try to say something but in the
end it's just it's horrible and and it's
and it doesn't work all the cliches you
know you know it was his time and maybe
that's true I don't
know um he's in a better place which I
do believe you know I grew up Catholic
I'm not so Catholic anymore but you I
still believe but time well which one of
your kids do you want to be in a better
place you know and not only that all
these people are people that haven't
been there you know they haven't been to
that place so how do you really know
it's that great you know that's another
thing when you lose a kid or lose your
spouse or you get really traumatized you
second guess everything what is heaven
really like what is Hell really
like um
and another thing that happens when you
lose a kid I think which is common is
you start reading up on all the
spiritualism like you know near-death
experiences
and or afterdeath Communications just
hoping to God that you know you'll hear
from him and he'll say he's
okay so after the accident um my
landlord gave us 60 days to get out with
without a good reason why we paid our
rent on time and everything and we've
been there for seven years that's where
I started my relationship with my wife
that's where we raised my son raised my
second
son and uh that's that's where we that
was the foundation of our our you know
our relationship and
family so
um I had a little bit of money uh
there's a life insurance policy very
small
and the school raised money for me so I
I had a little bit of money but we could
not find a place uh everything was so
expensive or they didn't want upfront
cash you know they wanted you to have a
job and have some outrageous credit
which my credit was decent but it wasn't
amazing uh so we ended up in a hotel in
a motel for about 3
months um which was horrible you know am
I going to be here till my money runs
out what's what's going to happen to me
are we all going to be
homeless the only thing good about that
Motel was it was about two blocks away
from the cemetery so I'd go visit my son
two three times a
day and then maybe about a month into it
you know I just fell apart and I started
crying and I was asking him if he could
like is there some way that he could
like say hi or let me know for sure that
he's okay or or show up or do something
like I I need I need this like I need a
receipt you know and they start praying
like I don't know if I'm supposed to
pray for this God but like this is
pretty traumatic and you you come down
and talk to me just for a second like
that's all I need just like everything's
okay you
know of course I didn't get that but
there was a lot of those
moments and I noticed that when he
passed I would do this thing every day
sometimes multiple times a day where I
would drive to his
school and then I'd drive to the place
that we lived at which we didn't live
anymore and then i' go to the cemetery
over and over and over
again and it took me about a year and a
half to realize what I was doing I was
looking for my son because my son was at
the school you know and I know that he
lived with
us and um I know he ended up at the
cemetery and then when I realized that's
when I started to realize well I mean
it's weird how your brain does things
that you don't know you know don't
understand it but I was able to figure
out that I was searching for my
son
uh the kid was 19y old excuse me the kid
was 19 years old who hit me and he had a
prior DUI I think three or four months
earlier and the court case basically
started to gather its momentum and then
covid hit so I couldn't go to court a
lot of it was uh like done with cameras
and it dragged for like two and a half
years and then um the da who's a great
da told me look um there's a chance that
he might get out and might
walk and the reason why was because he
was saying that the car locked up on
him so I'm a truth Seeker I I like to
confront the truth like I don't even if
I have a strong belief system like I
just want to know what the truth is just
just give me
truth so I looked up everything I could
about that car and that car did have
issues locking up you know it would lock
up and things would happen but the thing
is there was no skid marks in the
accident scene so the car didn't lock up
but if if the da wasn't able to prove
that his car didn't lock up with
something better than that he could
walk but the thing is is he was in there
for two and a half
years and um he was already tired of
waiting that can kill you not knowing
it's better to know that something
really bad is going to happen or
something good but the waiting will kill
you so
um he asked he wanted to take a
plea and uh my da asked if it was okay
if he' got 14
years and I I don't think that's enough
but at the same time the offer was that
he wouldn't get any credit for the time
that he was in there so he'd have to
wave all that and if he um got a
degree or he started healing people in
there there was nothing he could do he
had to do 14
years and so I talked with my wife about
it and we said okay he's going to be
younger than me when he gets out he's
going to be younger than me when when he
hit me when he gets
out
um my wife couldn't make it because this
was during Co and we had a dentist
appointment for my other son so she had
to go to that otherwise she wouldn't be
able to take him for 4 months you know
was so scheduled ahead of
time so uh the da called me the very
next day and said okay it's going to be
tomorrow so we're going to hurry up and
do it and then and it'll be
over so I showed up by myself um they
opened up a courtroom just for us so it
was just me my da you know the the court
people and uh one person showed up for
him who was his girlfriend I I
think and um
he was already all tattooed up in his
face he's playing the game I assumed to
survive in
prison and the da told me the other
court cases nobody ever came for him his
mom didn't come to support him or his
dad no friends
nothing so as much as he ruined my life
like that still sucks that this guy has
nobody so um they start running down all
the accounts and he has to sign all the
paperwork and I can feel my blood
boiling like I want to I want to hurt
this guy you know um just to look at him
and he even had a tattoo of a teardrop
you know and I know that that's for my
son you know they took my son's life
that he's a murderer and I guess he's
probably trying to do that to be cool or
so they don't hurt him in
prison so we're doing the whole Court
thing and the da says oh and my my
client would like to address the
court which I didn't tell her I wanted
to do that uh and it was so quick
everything happened so quick I didn't
write anything down and my brain doesn't
work correctly from The
Strokes so I got up there and my blood
is just boiling and I look at him and at
least he's looking at me I just said
look you know I forgive
you I said I forgive you but I want you
to own what you did I know that you
didn't this wasn't an accident your car
didn't lock up like you killed my son
because he made a bad decision if you
own that then your life will probably
work out better for you rather than ly
to yourself
and he kind of nodded and I said look
you know I'm never going to see my son
graduate from high school I'm never
going to see him become a cop I'm never
going to meet his first girlfriend like
the decision you made you know it took
that away from
me and uh he just kept nodding and I
told him look like get a degree do
whatever you can in there and better
yourself and when you get out help
people that way my son didn't die for
nothing
and uh I made a comment that like as bad
as as bad as this life may have been at
least there's one person trying to
support him there trying to lift him up
a little
bit and then that was it very big of
you yeah um I don't think of myself as a
big person for that but I mean if you
don't forgive people it's just going to
make things worse for you yeah it's
going to eat you know eat you up and I
know he didn't do it on purpose it
wasn't like out to try to kill me or my
son and who knows maybe me not forgiving
him would make his life worse you
know I hope there's something big and
good that he's going to do in his
life
if from my forgiving him and telling him
to you know get your life
together and uh so that was basically
the court case it was nice that it was
over but it didn't resolve anything
anything you know if he did life it
wouldn't resolve
anything
um people don't
realize that when you lose a child even
if you have other kids you know a lot of
people say hey you got to be strong you
have another kid and it's like my God
you're right I didn't think about that
you
know people just don't get it it has
nothing to do with that I'm I'm not the
same person I was before the accident
you know I lost my son I feel like I'm
half a person less than that so I don't
even know how to be normal sometimes or
or talk to my son I don't feel like I'm
a good father I just don't know how
to I just don't know how you know I knew
how before and it's slowly coming to me
and I'm and I'm I'm happy that I'm here
to to be there with him
but and a lot of times I wish I I I I
had gone in the accident you know I mean
I wouldn't have to to deal with all this
I would be with my son yes I have
another son but just it's just too
traumatic
um I have the best wife in the world too
I know most people can't say that like I
literally found the one that was for me
you know my
soulmate um I know that's very rare
but she's perfect and we're just perfect
together um I don't know if you know the
statistics on people that lose kids but
if they lose a kid it's like a for sure
thing that they're going to get divorced
that was it AF ask yeah it's
like it's like 95% or something it's
it's ridiculous it made us
stronger um and she was very
patient she's been very
patient
um I I became disabled from the accident
so and I get a check every month and
it's nowhere near
enough um I had to move to uh area which
is very very cheap it's 2 and a half
hours away from my friends and family
and that
sucks
um but I just tell everybody it's just
it's just one day at a time to try
to just one day at a time you know what
keeps me going and this is horrible is
knowing that life isn't forever I'm
going to be dead soon sooner or later
one day each day that goes by I'm one
day closer to dying so I don't have to
deal with all the pain P The Chronic
pain from the accident which is
horrific um not as bad as losing a child
obviously
but and I was the typical man I didn't
go to the hospital for anything you know
I would go to CVS I'd go buy medication
unless I I felt like I was
dying I I wouldn't go to the
hospital but now I have to go to the
hospital um you know it hurts it hurts
to
walk um my brain doesn't work the way
it's supposed to work I forget things
constantly um my wife has to repeat
herself and she's such an angel about it
but I know it gets annoying you know
especially to other
people you could tell you could you
could be right next to me telling me
something and then I'll ask you the same
thing two or three
times I used to have a photographic
memory before the accident it's what
separated me from everybody else I could
remember all these little details about
their lives and to be so turned
on you know that somebody actually
listened to what they had to say even
the small details and they even more so
that you'd remember that about them I
can't uh begin to tell you how many
people really got turned on by that you
know obviously women love that but just
male friends that told me that it's
great if they ever have dementia I'll
remember everything for
them and that's another thing um with
The Strokes I'm more likely to get
dementia Alzheimer's I mean how much
time do I have
you
know I mean I hope I don't get it but
you just you just don't
know you and I was right on the right
path too before before the accident you
know business was doing
well I I knew where everything was going
and just life through a monkey wrench in
there what has this done to your belief
in
God
like I said I grew up Roman Catholic I
considered being a priest when I was 17
well not a priest but a deacon which is
a a level
below um basically if you get married
before you be become a deacon it's okay
but if you become a deacon then you
can't get married so that's only reason
why I thought that you know I'd become a
deacon But as time went by I just
thought it made more sense to me just to
to be a non-denominational Christian and
I really walked the walk even friends
who were
atheists and people who struggled with
their belief system told me that I was I
was basically a good guy that I really
followed it very
well H but with the
accident I still
believe but I think we're going to come
back I I believe that reincarnation is a
part of it uh that's become my belief
system now maybe it's a defense
mechanism cuz the trauma is so
horrible um
yeah so
um I hope that
maybe my son will come back in some way
and know I'll know that it's you know
it's him I I know it sounds so
outrageous but I mean
I the only people that will understand
are people that have lost a kid
you and from what I've read I mean
everybody knows a bunch of things have
been taken out of the
Bible um and the Bible is used to
control a lot lot of
people uh supposedly there's a a lot of
scriptures in there that kind of elude
to the fact that there is
reincarnation
so I'm a Christian who believes in
[Music]
reincarnation it's great that you
haven't taken to alcohol or drugs or
anything like that uh it's funny you
bring that up
um I used to like to drink here and
there it was never a problem I had never
been drunk in my life
but I'd like to drink with friends and
you know hang out never did anything
stupid but after the accident it's like
you know they say every seven years you
have a body
change I think either I had a body
change or God did something because I'm
pretty sure I was destined to be an
alcoholic after what happened but
alcohol just doesn't have the same
effect I can have a few drinks and I
don't feel anything and then I just got
a headache pretty quickly after or the
next day so it's like I don't have a
vice to deal with it I have to just deal
with it
which it's good it's bad it's good for
my family but it's bad for me in a sense
that I just don't have any release or I
can't like forget about
[Music]
it and uh having to deal
with that's another thing the physical
pain you know
I I didn't realize how many doctors
don't want to give out pain pills no
matter what your situation is
or you get to a pharmacy and oh what are
you taking them for or what's your issue
and they're saying it right in front of
everybody you know so having to deal
with that I'm a legit Case by you know a
millionfold and
um there just something has to be done
um when you're on pain pills for a while
they have to send you to pain
management um um so I've been looking
for one and two of them right off the
bat said either our opiate panel is full
or we don't give out opiates we do
Interventional stuff it's like what are
you going to do what could possibly like
and I know you can hypnotize yourself
and all that you know I do that all the
time when I'm in pain like I'll think
about something I'll really try to focus
on it to forget that I'm in pain but it
takes a lot of work and you can't do
that all the
time so
um
Physical Therapy that puts you in more
pain and I understand that it's going to
give you more range of motion and I'll
do that all day long you know I'll do
whatever they tell me
but I need the pain pills I mean they
they help at least for now like I'm open
to if you want to try something else
let's try it but it really bothers me
that they make it so
difficult you know and and sometimes
everything is fine but the pharmacist
says no he has to call your doctor and
then a day goes by two days go by three
days go by and you don't have
anything and if you try to help yourself
by let's say you have a 30-day Supply
okay and it ends on the 30th you can't
call on the 27th because then it looks
like you're a drug addict even though
you're trying to make sure there's no
issues that you'll have your pain pills
by that time so you have to deal with
all that you know and then they then you
stop getting them and then what do you
do I mean
for me I just all I could do is be on a
recliner and watch
TV and I really can't get off I can go
to the restroom I can I'll try to go for
a little ride but I can't stand too long
I it hurts to sit you know I can't find
any any
comfort and then also when you're in
pain that's when all the thoughts of
your son come come back you know and was
there something I could have
done you know I think that I part of
it's my fault you know um I think that I
should have been really concentrating
why don't people drive like that all the
time where they're so heavily I mean it
doesn't make any sense you can't do that
but I think
that there's times where if I had just
really paid attention to everything all
the time none of this would have
happened which is completely
irrational then you get caught up in the
what ifs what if what if I just went
home and didn't take him to go get his
fish what would have happened would the
accident have happened on a different
street because it was this time go
like um I understand we have free will
and all that but sometimes things happen
and you it doesn't seem it seems like
there's something else a different Force
working you
know
um
yeah so my big thing right now is just
trying to be a good a father for my son
and and be a good husband and be a good
friend that's another
thing when you lose a child or you lose
your
spouse people just
disappear and and I've heard this from
other people it's common um I guess most
people only want to be around when it's
things are fun or things are okay but
they don't want to be around you when
you went through a traumatic loss cuz
then you're going to bring them down at
least that's where I I think it
is which is horrible you know I mean
if you're a true friend you should be
around all the time you know I am to my
friends like I'll be there when it's
depressing
and I'll do whatever I can but um a lot
of my friends and family disappeared
like they just disappeared they don't
call and I've reached out I did
everything I could reached out a few
times
and you know and some of them even
admitted to me that they just didn't
know what to say after the accident it's
like well you can say hi you can you can
ask me if I need anything or we can go
get coffee I'm not going to like cry the
whole time like I want some of my life
to come
back and uh that part hasn't it's really
affected that
much
um I'm trying to get back um you know I
want to work again I want to be able to
support myself and not be on SSI it's
difficult
I was able to photograph a wedding for
the first time and I did really well
but I was basically in my room for two
days you know sleeping and just getting
over it I was in pain and I had to take
you know an extra dose of pain pills to
to get through the wedding and they had
no
idea but I
mean like what am I what am I supposed
to do with what the cards have been
dealt to
me the only people that understand what
it's like to lose a child is somebody
who lost a
child
um it's like being in the middle of the
ocean and you like and it's very very
deep and you have to just keep you know
staying above water and that's your life
now you know nothing's ever going to
come under you so you can just kind of
breathe for a second and you can
relax you always out there in the middle
of the ocean with basically nobody and
you're just trying to stay afloat and
and that's basically what it's like
after you lose a
kid what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned from all
of
this that you never know what's going to
happen um and don't be one of those
people that say
um well things can't get any worse it's
like no things can always get worse they
can always get
worse period so don't say that things
can't get
worse
um yeah you never know what's going to
happen
and I know it's difficult but try kind
of treat every day like it's your last
like be nice to people you know tell
people you love them you know I message
a lot of people all the time I just say
hey I was thinking about you I hope
you're doing well you know just so they
know somebody's thinking about them and
I took my time either day to text them
that I never get
that but I know how how good that feels
because I want that so I do that to
everybody have you always been this
evolved a person this compassionate a
person this empathetic
um I don't feel like I am but other
people tell me I am for you to be saying
those saying that you do those things
given your circumstances is um and I and
I did that before the accident you know
I just really valued friendship and I
know that friendship really it's very
rare
my father I used to tell my father um
you know I'm going to go to my friend's
house or my friend's going to come over
and he'd start laughing and he would say
let me tell you about friends and I'd
get so
annoyed and he'd say in your whole life
in your whole life real true genuine
friends you'll be able to count on one
hand and you're going to have many
fingers left
over and I completely get it I
completely get it now I wish I could I
wish I could talk to him he passed away
in
2016 I wish I could talk to him and say
like yeah I'm sorry and his dad had told
him that and he used to get so turned on
by like
uh Kirsty Ali I you know that she went
to court for Kelsey Grammar when he was
an alcoholic to try to talk to judge and
say look this is a great guy he's just
going through some issues that's a real
friend you know when they're uh when
they'll accompany you at your lowest and
try to figure out something try to help
you in any
way um that's the kind of person I am
that's and I want to get better and
better at it yeah including people I
don't know on the street and I just want
to be helpful and help people
and and I want to educate people that
that's that's why everybody needs to be
on a certain level yes people are going
to take advantage of you here and there
but who cares that's
life you're very
impressive impressive thank you very
much I appreciate
that that doesn't mean um that doesn't
mean that life isn't hard you know life
is always going to be kind of difficult
on a certain
level and you'd be surprised a lot of
people
don't want to be with somebody like that
or be a friend with somebody like that
because that's the case very
often my wife says this thing to when I
get
depressed which I'm depressed all the
time and then we had to move two and a
half hours away from where we've been
our whole lives
you know I get depressed say you know
nobody comes to visit us you know it's
pretty lonely here and she said well all
the people that matter are right here
and so that's what I really try to focus
on just my wife and my
son and I was hoping that this video
would just it stops one person from
drinking and driving maybe they're going
to be in a situation where they kill
somebody that's like all I want cuz then
that's one person that got
saved I was just on a trip I just got
back yesterday and we were on a highway
a two-lane Highway high
speed no no
median just a yellow line in between the
oncoming traffic and the in the rest of
my previously I I never thought that you
know drunk you know drunk drivers happen
but now after starting this project I
realize how many people are on drugs
like meth that'll keep you up for a week
and if you finally do fall asleep you
you're going to fall asleep behind a
wheel or
anywhere or or you have a seizure or a
heart attack or or whatever yeah there's
so many ways that that oncoming car and
you're in this big heavy vehicle going
75 mil hour can get you head on while
you're going 75 mil where I live uh
there's a 395 I don't know if you know
about that but that's supposed to be one
of the most dangerous if not the most
dangerous Highway in California and
people die all the time people are
trying to they cannot wait they have to
you know two-lane Highway they have to
cut off the truck they don't see the car
maybe it's overcast it's gray they don't
have their headlights on people die all
the time there's C there's dis sconos
everywhere which is like a lurs where
there's a cross like somebody died there
may there's some Catholic candles that
kind of
thing
yeah and it just it's a reminder that
like you never know when you're going to
go and people die all the time I mean
from the moment we're born we're
dying
um
yeah
so I just hope something happens to
where it gets a little easier I know
that that's what everybody wants but I
just want
stability like I just want to make
enough to pay the bills and then put
something away but in California that's
getting increasingly difficult you
know and I don't want to be on SSI
forever like it's just it's it's very
difficult it's so hard to make
it the town I live in is great too it's
great everybody's so nice there's no
traffic there's no
people but it's too far away people want
don't want to come and see you like when
I come down the hill I visit anybody I
matter of fact after this I want to go
visit somebody you know like I want
everybody to know that I I care and I I
want I want to see you you know it's the
most valuable thing you can do is give
somebody your time
you
so at the same
time like coming here it's it's
difficult like God there's so many
there's just so many cars you know I
mean I've only been up there
since March
of
2021 and there's there's no traffic over
here there's so much it's like and
everybody drives like an [__] you
know I mean everybody Cuts everybody off
even if they don't need to be in your
lane if they see you going fast they
feel they have to go faster to get in
front of you like
it it's just it's so hard to deal
with but at the same time I mean this is
same yeah this is where everything
happens you know this is where the work
is this is where people are where the
opportunity is yeah where grocery stores
are that kind of thing you know this is
this is where it's all
happening
um after a
divorce I kind of saw it coming
but my plan was to have a loft in LA and
just do portraits and just be by myself
and never get married again that's what
my plan was you
know but then you just meet somebody and
everything is so random and
then you know you had to think that
there's some kind of synchros
synchronicity or God exists for
something like that to happen that you
were divorced before you were yeah I was
married I was married twice uh I was
married twice before I got got married
very very
young uh
19 kind of a high school sweetheart but
we didn't go to High School uh
together I blame myself for a large part
of that I didn't know how to communicate
very well and she had some issues which
I'm not going to say but it could have
worked um but I blame myself mostly for
that got married again um and there was
so many signs not to get married but I
felt so bad for her and and I wanted to
help and I blame myself so much for my
first marriage that I just tried to
stick it out 7
years and she had an affair
and wish I would have never met
her but after that I met my current wife
and this is you know I remember that
lawyer that uh that you interviewed well
soulmates do exist buddy I know it's
extremely rare but I mean it does happen
and if he had one he would completely
understand somebody that you can
completely be yourself you don't have to
act like somebody else you don't have to
worry about anything you're always going
to be supported they completely they
completely get it they understand who
you are better than you better than you
do you know it's one of the most amazing
things in the world yeah the fact that
you guys
can survive what you went through yeah
it's very impressive and there's so many
little things that go along with that
that I I haven't mentioned you know
losing a kid it
just it wrecks so much you
know it's very hard not to fall apart
you know I'll be
uh I'll be like farmer boys with friends
and all of a sudden I just start crying
like I just something will hit me or
I'll see a kid with glasses
or and I just fall
apart you know when am I going to see
him is um are the atheists right my God
I hope not um you know you just second
guess everything about your
life it's a horrible place to
be believe it or not I had two other
accidents after the accident the really
bad
one to get out of the hotel um my aunt
let us stay at her rental because the
people weren't paying so we're there for
about 2 and a half years and all of a
sudden she tells me uh you guys got to
leave because my daugh daughter can't
find a place and she needs to live there
so we had 60 days to find a place we
couldn't find
anything and then my wife randomly says
do you know where rich Crest is I was
like yeah you know how far away that
is she's like well I don't know what you
want me to do but you know we we have 14
days so I was like We'll go check it out
tomorrow and it was great you know we
checked out the town went to Walmart
first see the people and the place was
nice it was a house with a garage and
everything we needed and it was super
cheap so we moved over there
and I know moving sucks and I wouldn't I
don't want to ask somebody to help me
cuz moving
sucks so I overdid it and I fell out of
the U-Haul and I re-broke my femur left
one again they had to pull the rod out
put it back in attach it to my hip my
hip
broke so basically I was on the recliner
and I just watched a b bunch of soft
white underbelly I had watched it before
a little bit here and there
but I really love to meet Hutch man like
he just reminds me a
lot he has all the trauma but he has his
son and his son's beautiful you know
like I wish like I just wish I could
talk to him CU I don't have my son you
know that's another thing like I'm
afraid that like I'm not going to be
able to give my son my new my my second
son like all the love that I give my
first or maybe it won't feel like I am
but I am I don't know like God damn dude
losing a kid just [__] you all up you
know of course I want to be the best dad
ever
um but how do you do that with the
circumstances I had a very good
friend um who passed away this is right
before I met my wife I almost think that
God put him in my
way uh because that's what I needed
after my divorce cuz I was so trauma
ized and I asked him cuz you know I'd
gotten my current wife pregnant and I
said do you think I'm going to be a good
dad he's like you're going to be the
greatest dad in the world and for him to
tell me that cuz he was the most
critical man on Earth if if there was
something bad about me he would have
told me and so when he told me that I
was like oh wow okay and then somebody
else who's pretty much as bad as him
told me the same thing so I knew that
maybe I'm just too hard on myself or I
can't see things sometimes you need
somebody to show you your blind spot
you
know cuz you really can't see
yourself so I just want to be a good dad
and continue to be a good husband and
and
finish you know suicide
is I can't begin to tell you like how
often that's on my mind especially with
the pain and it's so easy you know but I
just try to finish this day you know
when it's really bad takeing an hour at
a time take it a minute at a time that's
nice night time let's go to bed and then
start all over it's only been a couple
years well May 7th 2019 so yeah oh four
years yeah few
years and uh you know my mom lost her
firstborn to a car accident
uh he had a beer so technically drinking
and driving and I remember I asked her
how long cuz I I was thrashed in the
beginning I'm still thrashed I was like
how long did it take you to where
like you're at least able to function
and kind of like just
flow she said 5 years and I was thinking
like there's no [__] way like 5 years
that's that's too long like I'm going to
there's no way I can do
that and I asked his dad because we have
different fathers and I said how long
and he
said five years he said the exact same
thing and I was like oh my God there's
no way but it'll be here shortly and
you're almost there yeah
well from what I see you're doing great
I appreciate it thank you very
much I have good days and I have bad
days it's not always like
this
so well Peter thank you so much for for
sharing your story with us thank you for
allowing me to come
here